now with more Texas Senator Ted Cruz the
man himself Georgia's Senate candidate
Herschel Walker and South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham Herschel I saw
the contest with you and Lindsay doing
the push-up contest now when we did it
together I did a hundred push-ups he
only did 34. what's up with that
well you know that was a start he was
doing it he read 34 so right now he's
already agreed he's going to do 50. if
everyone would give him 50 dollars so I
got to tell everyone out there donate 50
to teamhearsal.com and things are going
to do 50 push-ups for us you know you
well first of all say you could say hi
to the crowd for me uh I I know you guys
just had a big rally there and I'm glad
Senator Cruz Senator Graham to see you
guys there by the way Senator Cruz how
many push-ups can you do
look I'm a debater and a lawyer so I'll
just argue about it while you guys are
doing by the way that's a good answer
um so this race is important maybe some
people don't think it's important I
think it is important Lindsey Graham
will ask you we'll start with you why
does this race matter I know you and Ted
Cruz and many others have pretty much
parked out in Georgia to help out team
Herschel
yeah
well let me tell you what Schumer said
about this race a 50-50 Senate slows
everything down so it makes a big
difference to us so from schuber's point
of view herschel's a nightmare for his
desire to change America from my point
of view he's saving America so if
Schumer thinks herschel's getting in his
way uh help Herschel Team hershel.com 17
million dollars has been spent in the
last 10 days on TV ads for Warnock five
for Herschel there's three million
people watching tonight if 10 percent of
you gave something if you could it
raises millions of dollars we're going
to win this race because we can't afford
to lose Herschel is going to change the
senate for the better Schumer knows this
they're trying to throw everything but
the kitchen sink so what can you do to
help this fine man you can go to the
website give money if you can pray vote
and give
all right Ted Cruz I I this has been a
very hard election to analyze but I
don't think there's any doubt under the
guise of gold covid voting has changed
in this country and it looks like the
left and the Democrats are way more
comfortable with mail-in balloting and
early voting than conservatives and
Republicans are if I had my system it
would be election day is a national
holiday paper ballots uh we'd have six
signature identification and voter ID
we'd have partisan observers watch the
voting watch the vote counting that
night we'd call a winner like Canada
does in the French too and and Israel
and you know some Great Britain all
these other countries do uh that's not
that's the system we want it's not the
system we have so do Republicans and
conservatives need to get over the
reluctance and resistance to mail-in
ballots and early voting that they seem
to show
but listen there's no doubt that we need
to use every tool we can to turn out
votes every tool that is legal and and
right now we're in a Sprint we'll have
plenty of time to engage in
retrospectives about election day in the
weeks and months to come December 6th is
this runoff and this runoff makes a huge
difference in Georgia I believe Herschel
Walker is going to win but it's a
hundred percent a turnout game it
depends who shows up the left they're
going to bust people out they're going
to try to turn out their radical base
that they've got organizers that are
very effective and so this is really a
call to the common sense people of
Georgia the people who believe in in in
Freedom to people who believe in
supporting the police to people who
believe in supporting the military to
people who oppose the Socialist agenda
that Raphael Warnock votes for Chuck
Schumer has told you he doesn't want
Herschel Walker to win he doesn't want a
50-50 Senate why is that because in a
50-50 Senate the Committees are even
which slows them down if Rafael Warnock
wins Schumer can expedite
confirming radical judges to take away
your free speech rights your religious
liberty rights your second amendment
rights and so I want to say Sean to
everyone in Georgia come out and vote on
December 6th bring your friends bring
your family and if you're not in Georgia
go to team herschel.com team
herschel.com team herschel.com by the
end of it we're going to say this more
than Lindsay says his website and that's
impressive because I think he's got his
printed on his driver's license I I know
that what's the website today Lindsay
well nobody's going to outdo Lindsay on
this part I mean this guy is Shameless
but uh but you know what the reality is
what what he's saying is true is that
they've done nearly 20 million dollars
already in negative ads on herschel's
head and that does have an impact on
these races uh Herschel one thing I am
glad to see is that Governor Kemp who
really you know beats Stacey Abrams look
she was a person that said the worst
state to live in was the state she
wanted to govern uh I don't think that
went over well well in Georgia nor
losing the MLB All-Star game and the 100
million plus dollars to the economy that
she lost
but I understand Governor Kemp has
really gone above and beyond to help you
and and campaign for you on your behalf
and and stand up for you in this race uh
how important do you view that
endorsement now
well I view that endorsement very
important because right now Governor
Kemp and I we can roll the boat in the
same direction you know Governor Kemp
can do it on the state level and I can
help him on the federal level whereas
Raphael wonoff has rode a boat against
Governor Kemp and almost everything
Governor Kemp has tried to do and I
think all the voters of Georgia need to
know to get Georgia back up going to
where it should be going we got to get
people in the boat rolling in the same
direction that'll be me and that's
sending along working with Governor Kemp
that's when Georgia going to see Jordan
Blossom even more
you know I want to ask Lindsay you the
same question I was asking Ted and that
is it's very it's an uphill battle if
Republicans and conservatives if they
were if they don't like this system we
have I want to change it I just
explained that to Senator Cruz but we
have the system that we have I wish I
could change it I wish I could Snap My
Fingers I can't but the reality is is
Democrats have embraced early voting
mail-in voting Republicans conservatives
have not and that means often is the
case that you come to election day and
you're 30 percentage points behind and
you got to catch up all day that's not
an easy thing to do do you think
Republicans and conservatives at least
for the time being have to face what the
reality is and work with the system
that's stuck with
yeah here's the reality if we can uh
elect Herschel it's much harder for
shooter and in 2024 we have West
Virginia Ohio and Montana three very
good pickups so if you start at 50 50
all you need is one two years from now
with the fire Schumer we just fired
Nancy Pelosi this is the road defying
Schumer begins tonight am I Shameless
shame on us all if we can't help him
this guy has taken a lot of crap he
stood out he's an African-American
conservative all hell is broke loose
against him and his family the least we
can do yes shame on us all if we can't
help him because he's going to change
the Republican Party he's going to
change America go to teamhercial.com and
unashamingly give to an African-American
conservative who deserves your support
team herschel.com change America change
it now thank you
I don't know it's Senator Cruz you want
to try and top that
well look
I'll say you look at all the voting
rules that the Democrats used covid to
put in place this election here in
Georgia will determine whether those
rules get forced all over the country
because if Warnock wins the Democrats
are one vote away from ending the
filibuster and I think if they get one
vote away from ending the filibuster Joe
manchin will roll over Schumer will end
it and the first thing they will do if
they end the filibuster is pass S1 the
corrupt politicians act that will strike
down every photo ID law in the country
that will legalize ballot harvesting
that that will register millions of
illegal aliens to vote that will
register felons to vote they want to
stay in power and this race is all about
taking the terrible voting laws in
California and forcing them on the rest
of this country I want to say secondly
what Lindsay just said a minute ago is
really important why do the Democrats
hate Herschel so much because he's a
black man who's a conservative who has
the courage to speak out and and the
attitude of the Democrats is the is that
African-Americans and Hispanics we're
not allowed to believe in Freedom we're
not allowed to support the cops we're
not allowed to want to secure our
country we're definitely not allowed to
believe in the Constitution and the Bill
of Rights and that is a lie and they
want to punish Herschel for Darren to
speak out because they're scared of him
because when he wins and Sean I believe
he's going to win he is going to be a
national leader that is going to
resonate across the country in the
African-American Community with young
people and with Americans all over the
country who are fed up with the
directions we're going you know Herschel
I I've watched that's pretty good that's
a close second
I've watched you in this campaign and I
remember
we had we had a conversation Herschel
before you ran and in that conversation
I said you know they're going to smear
you slander you besmirt you character
assassination you said you said to me
you were ready for it and you know he
said let him bring it on and I wish I
was wrong but all of that turned in
turned out to be true I think one thing
Herschel and I'll let you talk to the
rest of the country you know we have 49
other Republican Senators around the
country and why this is important to
them is that you'll be 50 and that will
help their Republican Senators Advance
the agenda that they all went out and
voted for which is why it matters to
everybody in the country let's get your
thoughts Herschel Walker
well first of all this election is more
than Herschel Walker this direction is
about the people and I said this is we
the people not we the government and
that's what the left want to do is make
it the government well I want everyone
to know I love the United States of
America I love Georgia and that's what
this is about bringing this country back
to being the United States of America
and not some not China not Russia
because that's what the left scene want
to do they don't like the term make
America great again I think it was a
wonderful term I live in America I want
it to be great but I want everyone in
America to be a part of it and I want
Americans that's the reason I said let's
secure this border that's what Senator
Warner has voted not to do is security
border let's get this economy back
together let's get crime off the street
it can be done and we unify and come
together as people rather than Do It
Center the one I continue to do is want
to divide us just for a vote so I want
all the people in Georgia to know right
now I'm a unified I want to come
together and just make this country
great again make Georgia great again
because that's what we're about
all right I think we're going to end it
there on a great note uh Senator uh Ted
Cruz thank you Lindsey Graham thank you
and hopefully soon to be Senator elect
it's coming in two weeks Herschel Walker
uh thank you please send my regards to
that massive crowd behind you as well
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else